das ist wahrscheinlich der fall der wie
kein zweiter die praxis des
justizvollzugs in zürich aber auch in
der ganzen schweiz verändert hat frank
urbaniok ist der einflussreichste und
wohl auch bekannteste gerichtspsychiater
der schweiz
wenn die medien fragen haben liefert er
antworten
wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten fälle dienen er als
gutachter zu tun hatte 1993 ermordete
ein insasse der justizvollzugsanstalt
verschließt auf einen bewilligten
hafturlaub die 20 jährige pascal pro
mann in zürich zollikerberg der täter
war zu einer lebenslangen
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt die absaß und
er hatte zum zeitpunkt dieses deliktes
bereits früher vielfach eigentumsdelikte
begangen
elf vergewaltigungen und zwei
sexualmorde der verdacht fiel sofort auf
erich hauert
denn der grausame mord trug eine klare
handschrift die der polizei von hartz
früheren verbrechen bestens bekannt war
überführt wurde er mit hilfe von
blutspuren an seiner armbanduhr
als klar war dass dieses blut der
ermordeten pascal brumann gehörte
gestand er die tat
man hat es hier eindeutig mit dieser art
von täter zu tun die extrem gefährlich
und langfristig lebenslangen behandelbar
sind
es zeigt sich eine solche massive
brutalität und eine penetranz des der
gewalt und der tendenz wir nennen das
qualifizierte vergewaltigungs
disposition
zusammen mit der bereitschaft zu töten
das ist tief in der persönlichkeit
verwurzelt hat zu ganz vielen delikten
geführt und das ist etwas was dann so
stark in der persönlichkeit verankert
ist
mit einer solchen penetranz dass es da
nicht um therapie geht sondern darum die
bevölkerung langfristig vor deutschen
tätern zu schützen
der fall erschüttert die schweiz wie ist
es möglich dass einem solchen menschen
unbegleitete haft urlaube bewilligt
werden und er weiter morden kann
die verantwortlichen erklären den
unbegleiteten hafturlaub damit dass
howard trotz lebenslänglicher
freiheitsstrafe bald hätte entlassen
werden müssen
darauf habe man ihn vorbereiten wollen
es ist so wir sind wieder straff
verstaut runde bei friedrichs grollt der
sexualtäter weitere kategorie wo im
bezug auf die öffentlichkeit des cortex
potenzial darstellt praktisch alle der
täterin der strafe in der regel zwischen
240 und ein einziger hat der sogenannt
lebenslängliche strafe und singen aber
so etwas wie der letzte dreck schiavone
übersee und strafrechtliche mir kein
einziger fall können und eine nie ein
lebenslang lebenslang lsk sondern immer
noch 15 bis 16 jahre und loben oder sind
sind die unabhängigen gerichten das sind
gericht ein urteil fällen und in dem
fall oc c a gehört die justizbehörde
hätte verwahrung beordert staatsanwalt
hätte verwaltungsgericht hat dimitri
maßnahmen nämlich das lebenslängliche
freiheitsstrafe
urban york kam zwei jahre nach dem mord
in die schweiz und stellte schnell fest
dass diese erklärungen zu kurz griffen
also ich glaube das ist eine verzerrung
der tatsächlichen verhältnisse und das
ist doppelt falsch denn zum einen muss
man sagen
es gab gar keinen hinderungsgrund
lebenslange freiheitsstrafen auch
lebenslang zu vollziehen das wäre
rechtlich auch damals möglich gewesen
die praxis war halt anders und zum
zweiten war es so dass die verwahrung
die damals ausgesprochen wurden
dazu führten dass die täter in aller
regel nach drei oder vier jahren
entlassen wurden das führte zum teil zu
der paradoxen reaktionen der gerichte
dass die gerichte dann aufgrund dieser
praxis gesagt haben bevor der
gefährliche täter nach drei oder vier
jahren wieder auf der straße steht
beantragen wir lieber eine endliche
freiheitsstrafe von 15 12 jahren dann
ist er länger drin was natürlich das
problem nur zeitlich nach hinten
verschoben hat also diese analyse wenn
man sie so bezeichnen will die ist ein
ich würde sagen eine die falsch ist und
die eigentlich die wirklichen probleme
eher zudeckt als aufzudecken
der fall hat hat laut urban york einen
systemfehler des damaligen
strafvollzuges offen gelegt das große
problem sei gewesen dass eine art
ideologische brille vielen
verantwortlichen die sicht auf die
realität verzerrt habe die 68er sind ja
eine zeit in der ganz viele auch
wichtige gesellschaftliche reformen
angestoßen worden sind in dem man viele
sachen neu gedacht hat überdacht hat und
in dem auch sagen zum teil verkorkst und
sehr autoritäre strukturen hinterfragt
und verändert worden das ist auch
sicherlich ein verdienst der 68er
aber die zeit hat auch ihre
nebenwirkungen und ihre schattenseiten
für den strafvollzug bedeutet dass die
68er haben stark propagiert die idee die
gesellschaftlichen zustände produzieren
kriminalität so ein bisschen nach dem
alten marxistischen grundsatz dass sein
prägt das bewusstsein und in dieser
optik ist dann nicht der einzelfall in
seiner differenzierten erfassung im
zentrum sondern es ist mehr etwas
globales jeder hat eine chance verdient
wir müssen sehen dass wir beruflich
qualifizieren dann begehen die menschen
noch keine delikte mehr
das sind die schattenseiten dieser ist
halt mal zum teil etwas naiven und der
generellen haltung zu sagen alle
straftäter sind irgendwie gleichen sind
symptome einer zeit sind symptome
gesellschaft und man muss sagen
kriminalitäts ursachen die
muss man vor allem im einzelfall
festmachen und da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche menschen ganz
unterschiedliche täter ganz
unterschiedliche risiken an
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten darauf
einzuwirken und dieser differenzierung
schritt der war damals hat sicher
gefehlt in einer generell zum teil auch
gesagt mal reformatorischen euphorie
dass man die ganze welt besser macht und
dass dann risiken in dieser optik wenig
in den blick genommen worden
der markt in zollikerberg erschütterte
den schweizer strafvollzug in seinen
grundfesten
es blieb fest kein stein auf dem anderen
der schutz der öffentlichkeit vor
gefährlichen tätern wurde zur ersten
priorität
das hat zb dazu geführt dass man
risikobeurteilungen standardmäßig
professionalisiert hat dass man gesagt
hat man muss sich um das risiko gedanken
machen ob das instrument entwickeln
das hat dazu geführt dass die therapien
sogenannt delikte orientiert
durchgeführt wurden also nicht mehr die
mutter stand im zentrum oder
irgendwelche alltäglichen kleinigkeiten
sondern vor allem das delikt verhalten
und das risiko die bewährungshilfe hat
sich geändert auch die wurde
risikoorientiert ausgerichtet das heißt
wenn man früher vielleicht eher die
tendenz hatte der bewährungshelfer ist
so ein bisschen wie ein kumpel der sich
auch um dinge kümmert dann ist der
bewährungshelfer dieser zeit ein
fachmann der sich auch für mit risiken
aus kennt die risiko zeichen erkennen
kann eine ganz andere große entwicklung
ist die differenzierung im strafvollzug
klassischer strafvollzug kommt aus der
idee alle haben das gleiche programm
wir kennen das aus dem fernsehen alle
haben die gleichen klamotten an die
haben das gleiche essen alles das
gleiche
und es war so ein bisschen die haltung
wenn drin ruhe und ordnung herrscht dann
hat der justiz vorzug der strafvollzug
hat damit seine pflicht und schuldigkeit
getan und wenn man sich das überlegt
dann weiß man aber es gibt ganz ganz
unterschiedliche tätergruppen im
strafvollzug da ist der drogenkurier aus
kolumbien oder der pädosexuelle mit dem
zweiten rückfall belegt oder eben ein
sexualmörder sind ganz unterschiedliche
problemstellungen und man hat dann
angefangen zu sagen man muss den
strafvollzug muss man differenzieren
andere tätergruppen andere
problemstellungen heißt andere angebote
man muss sich darauf einrichten und ganz
ganz wesentlich dass man gesagt hat
unsere pflicht und schuldigkeit hört
nicht damit auf dass es zu entlassungen
kommt und damit haben wir dann mit dem
fall nichts mehr zu tun sondern man hat
gesagt wir müssen auch verantwortung für
die zeit nach dem strafvollzug
übernehmen das sind einige der ganz
wirklich fundamentalen änderungen die
sich vollzogen haben und die das system
in der tiefe wirklich fundamental
verändert haben
große überraschung hochrisiko täter
lebenslang wegsperren
das bekräftigte das stimmvolk 2004 mit
dem jahr zur verwahrungsinitiative mit
der umsetzung dieser initiative tut sich
die justiz schwer aber sie führte zu
einer generellen verschärfung der
verwahrungs praxis wer heute verwahrt
wird der hat kaum eine chance je wieder
entlassen zu werden
es ist ganz sicher so dass das pendel in
die andere richtung geschwungen ist und
dass man sehr sensibilisiert für risiken
ist und ich glaube auch an einigen
stellen das system überdreht das ist
ganz sicher so und ich bin ja ein großer
fan immer von differenzierung nicht von
pauschal entweder oder schwarz weiß
sondern sozusagen den einzelfall
anschauen und im einzelfall dann die
maßnahmen treffen die dem einzelfall
angemessen sind das kann auch mal eine
lebenslange verwahrung sein das kann
aber in vielen fällen etwas ganz anderes
sein aber es muss immer verhältnismäßig
4 am einzelfall festgemacht werden und
da kann man schon entwicklung und
beobachtung wo dann vielleicht auch
durch die prozesse durch bürokratische
prozesse durch immer mehr abläufe
kompliziert halten dass dann die
entscheidung so lange werden so
kompliziert werden dass der eine oder
andere unverdienterweise in dem system
hängen bleibt und das ist genauso zu
kritisieren und rechtsstaatlich genauso
bedenklich wie wenn auf der anderen
seite fehler passieren